Bonjour !
Vous allez voir une vidéo bonus que j'ai réalisé avec Norman
pour la soirée des 10 ans de la fondation Culture et Diversité,
qui aide les jeunes des milieux défavorisés
à accéder aux arts et à la culture.
Alors pendant cette soirée, on est montés sur scène
avec Norman pour présenter cette vidéo,
qui parle des musées, forcément sur la culture.
Et puis on s'est dit que ce serait dommage de ne pas vous la montrer à vous, les internautes.
Du coup c'est ce que vous allez voir, bon visionnage.
Moi souvent quand je vais au musée
Le mec va au musée quoi, le truc de riche. Je paye mon ticket pour voir des œuvres.
Alors là, non ! La plupart des musées ont des horaires de gratuité, voir sont totalement gratuit.
Le Louvres, par exemple, est gratuit pour les moins de 26 ans.
Ça ne coûte rien ! Y a pas moins cher que rien.
Bienvenue au musée, cela ne vous coûtera rien.
Ah ouais non mais moi parce que moi j'ai.. Je n'ai pas rien sur moi
Ah bah non ça va pas être possible, faut qu'on paye pas les gens tout ça..
Ça coûte rien quoi ..
Pff, bande d'altruistes.
Moi je suis altruiste moi ?
Viens ici !
Alors, il y a plein de musées avec des thèmes très variés.
Moi par exemple, j'adore la bande dessinée
Et il y a des très grands musées qui ont exposés des œuvres de...
Chuuuuuut !
Ah oui parce que c'est vrai que dans les musées il y a aussi des gardiens qui... C'est bon tu peux partir maintenant !
Souvent dans les musées, les gardiens demandent à garder le silence.
Autant dans une bibliothèque, je comprends, t'es en train de travailler, de lire, faut pas déranger les gens.
Mais dans un musée ça dérange qui ?
Les toiles ?
C'est super vieux ! Ça a quoi ? 3000 ans ? Un truc comme ça...
*tousse*
Y'a ma femme Néfertiti qui est dans son tombeau qui essaye de dormir
Donc euuh.. Ok ?
Il existe différents types de musée pour tous les goûts.
Art moderne, art contemporain, histoire naturelle
et même des musées spécifiques : le musée du chocolat par exemple.
J'y suis pas allé, il parait que c'est très bien mais c'est...
On expose du .. chocolat quoi..
Ouais.. Est-ce que tu sens l'impérialisme italien ?
Ouais, hyper badass !
Qui transfigure le Super Kilo, tu sens ça ?
Ouais ça je le sens ouais ouais.
Ça, et le chocolat ouais.
Ou que le chocolat ouais.
Chut ! Vous dérangez le Super Kilo là !
Hé y'a un papier de Milka là bas, c'est complètement what the fuck !
-Enorme !
Bon j'vais aller au musée du chocolat ça à l'air très bien
Et y'a aussi les musées d'art moderne.
Si vous allez dans ce genre de musées vous pouvez tomber sur
des performances.
C'est des gens qui font des performances.
Si vous avez jamais vu ça c'est... c'est assez surprenant.
Mondialisatiooooon,
MONDIALISATIOOOOON !
C'est quoi ce truc ?
Excusez-moi monsieur ! Ça c'est une œuvre d'art hein.
Ah pardon !
Performance !
Ah.. c'est...
Quand tu vas dans un musée et que tu vois une oeuvre que tu connaissais,
sauf la Joconde hein ça compte pas mais..
T'es un petit peu fier quand même
Tu fais: ah tiens ça je... ça je connais.
Ça c'est un artiste américain, c'est du cubisme, c'est euh...
Euh, il s'appelle euh... C'est euh...
Alors ça c'est une sortie de secours.
C'est une sortie de secours oui.. c'est vrai, c'est vrai...
J'ai remarqué que dans les musées d'art moderne, une grande partie des œuvres n'avait pas de nom.
Voilà, elles s'appellent sans nom, sans titre, untitled pour les anglais.
Les mecs s'en foutent.
Ouais, mon œuvre elle a pas de nom parce que je suis contre les étiquettes, les formalités.
Voilà ça s'exprime à travers la spontanéité, ça n'a pas de nom.
Par contre elle a bien un prix, hein, y'a un prix je l'ai choisi.
Oui tout à fait, je prends la carte bleue d’ailleurs,
Plus les chèques, désolé.
Dans les musées y'a un type de personne c'est les..
Ce que j'appelle "les dessinateurs",
C'est souvent des étudiants en école d'Art comme ça qui ..
Qui dessine dans les musées quoi ..
J'pense qu'ils essayent de faire un petit peu mieux quoi ..
Moi j'aurais fait ça plutôt ..
A chaque fois que je vais dans un musée d'histoire naturelle que je vois
les ossements anciens là de nos ancêtres et tout,
j'me dit "Mais .. Mais p't'être qu'on peut terminer nous aussi dans un musée !"
Toi,
Moi,
Je sais pas.
Alors ici vous avez les Youtubers, hein qui ont, très peu marqué l'histoire.
Bon, même, pas du tout on peut le dire !
Bah d'ailleurs on va les débrancher.
J'pense que, c'est encore mieux.
Ah bah là bas on a le dab, hein qui est complètement disparu,
c'était un p'tit mouvement du 21ème siècle.
J'vous dis à très vite ! Et pensez à moi la prochaine fois que vous irez dans un musée et que vous verrez une sortie de secours.
Chuuut !
Nan mais, C'EST MA CHAINE JE PEUX PARLER FORT SI JE VEUX ! D'ACCord..
Ce n'est.. Ce n'est pas une performance artistique !
Chuut ! Vous allez vraiment finir par réveiller Néfertiti !